and i was shocked to get to know this
because i was born and raised in a
muslim family and i never
had this sense that it hasn't it had
nothing to do with reason
and then now you get infected the virus
is in you
and bill cates can't get it and bill
gates can't get it out it is too much
evidence it's so much evidence that i
believe it is an insult to islam to try
to
tackle that within a few minutes
[Music]
of peace how are you guys doing i hope
you are having a blessed ramadan we have
an amazing guest for you
who went from practicing cultural islam
to actually finding
the real deal the real dean
based on evidence and proof so he went
from the cultural version
to actually leaving islam becoming an
atheist and we see a lot of this going
on
so he didn't have a strong foundation
until really investigating what's the
purpose of life why am i here
and the proof upon proof the evidence
upon evidence was so overwhelming
that he ended up coming back to the
demons he's here to share his story he
even went above and beyond
and got his ba in islamic studies and he
ended up
forming an academy that's helping to
educate
the hispanic community the spanish
community the latino community
my next guest is here with us don't go
anywhere all the way from spain
we'll be right back
you're in spain right yes uh
i'm in spain i'm actually half spanish
my mother is spanish
so here i am now you got a very
interesting story because many people
can relate
born in a muslim family but then you
kind of took a turn
towards atheism how did that happen
well um it was a process
and even myself i i then had to study my
own process
to understand it but i guess it was
probably because of the
uh education system you know no one
comes and tells you you have to be an
atheist but
this is a process you start like um
absorbing a whole worldview you know
it is a worldview that you were taught
even without you realizing it
so it was little by little until i
realized that i did not believe
you know suddenly i just came to realize
that you know
all religions are the same you know god
doesn't exist
we have scientific explanations you know
that's that you you don't realize it and
you have become an atheist by
when you are 13 when you are 12 years
old
you're an atheist already is that's how
old you were
yeah that young so you you attribute a
lot of this to the schooling system
yeah the schooling system and the fact
that
i was actually like a very rational
person
and unfortunately when you grow up
in a in some sometimes within muslim
families
you don't get to learn the deen as
something uh
like based on proof you know so you you
come to learn the religion
you come to learn the traditions of the
family the superstitions of the family
and uh there comes a time in which you
just go to the
you just go to high school you uh
you meet a lot of people with their own
beliefs and their own superstitions and
no one
uh knows how to justify why you believe
what you believe
so at the end you just lose your faith
because actually
you are a muslim because of blind faith
and this is a world in which
religion is not a comfort zone anymore
unless you have a very solid grounding
and foundation in your religion you will
lose it that's
guaranteed did you go through any
struggle internal struggle
between because you mentioned there was
a blind
following just from the beginning so you
didn't really have a good foundation in
the dean
to begin with is that correct
you know uh the fact of the matter is
that um
the way i was taught islam it was not a
bad way you know and our parents did
whatever they could
but there was no proof you know so i
i just tried hard to believe before
becoming an atheist
but i i would ask questions i didn't get
any answers
and um i just you know my best friend
was an atheist
so and actually what he was saying
sometimes made more
sense so it was a little by little
you know your iman was lost and uh
it was actually a while before i started
to study islam
and study islam by myself and read the
quran
and that's when everything began to
change and i realized that a lot of
things about islam i didn't even know
were you practicing islam before you
didn't know much
you were saying but were you were your
in your home was there a practice of it
the the prayer fight times a day the
fasting
the zakat the the other the other things
that
a muslim does daily in his life
yeah this is an interesting question
because uh most of muslim families are
very practicing in some things
and they don't practice at all in other
things and that was the situation
like for example we were not very strict
about the prayer
however we used to fast you know we
don't eat pork because we're muslims
however um other things about islam you
know you don't even
come to know them so we we were like a
practice like a regular practicing
muslim family with it
with the typical inconsistencies that
that you will find in many practicing
so-called muslim families
you mentioned something about a friend
and you
there's a hadith a authentic
prophetic statement from the last and
final messenger sent to mankind prophet
muhammad peace and blessing to be upon
him who said that the person is upon the
way of his friends
and you are just a living testimony to
this coming to fruition we see this a
lot
that now you actually started to follow
the way of your friend
yeah it was not just one friend but it
was
the whole the system the people i didn't
have like
true muslim friends so this was a
process
and i just found myself but it's
completely true this is a
completely true statement of the prophet
the person will take the friend from his
intimate actually
the word khalil refers to the intimate
friend you know not like someone you
know but someone you let into your
uh private circle that's the one that's
good good point intimate friends
somebody who now you share your intimate
secrets with
to someone that you're just like you
know having over sleep over
whatever the case really deep deep
connection yeah
that's that's powerful yeah because now
you see a lot of people
who will go ahead and take anyone as a
friend and that friend is
inviting them to the bar to the
nightclub and then they have their
philosophy they have their way
they've been also programmed and now
they're passing that along to you
and so you're not well grounded and then
now you get infected
the virus is in you and bill cates can't
get it and bill gates can't get it out
exactly that's exactly what happens
usually
you just get infected without even
realizing it you know
but now you went and you started to
research
talk to us about the next transition
what took you from that
state to now you're researching all over
again
yes well i was actually as i told you a
very rational person
the same reason that took me out of
that kind of cultural islam is the same
reason that took me back to real islam
and i i really thank god for that
because you know i i the first thing i
did is i read a translation of the quran
well this is a very long story obviously
but one of the things that i came to
believe is that religion is irrational
i mean in my atheist worldview that
religion
all religions are the same this is like
the akita like the doctrine of the
atheists the modern atheist
all religions are the same religion is
not something that you can prove it's
not based on
reason you just need to have blind faith
now the first translation that i read of
the quran
it's interesting that it was a bad
translation
but i came to know some basic facts and
one of the basic facts that i came to
know is that
islam was based on reason and i was
shocked to get to know this because i
was born and raised in a muslim family
and i
never had this sense that it hasn't it
had
nothing to do with reason one of the
things that struck me is that
you know when you become an atheist you
feel like you're becoming very rational
because
now you believe in science more or less
and uh
science science science and aliens
yeah yeah and you know there is like
this idea that
the universe has its laws and you don't
need god to explain them
but the way the quran integrates your
study of the universe
and getting to know his creator to me it
was revolutionary it's like
we have these dilemmas that you need to
follow science or follow
religion blindly and you know the quran
just
just allowed me to understand that this
is a false dilemma
that we are taught in this society so i
could learn about
the educational system and the modern
atheist
creed by reading the quran and realizing
that
behind all that so-called rationality of
the atheists
usually there is an uh actually a lot of
irrationality
people tend to believe in false dilemmas
like you need to
believe in science or i mean follow
science or religion and
actually my first reading of the quran
really got me to understand that
these are false dilemmas how much did uh
in your research you mentioned that you
came across the the dean show also and
that it had an
effect on you talk to us about that
most definitely uh when i began to
love islam the first translation that i
read was
pretty bad but then i read another which
was better
and it had some notes about the
coherence of the quran
because when you read some translations
you get this idea that the quran is
incoherent right
so i began to love the quran by reading
better translations and then i started
to research on the internet
and of course i came across the dean
show
those days i believe this was like 16 or
17 years ago maybe
those days you were recording uh you
were recording some interesting uh
shows with dr gilad phillips
and abdul rahim green and um
i remember that those had an impact on
me because i i
even got to know a lot of muslim
preachers through the dean show
and that was really inspiring you know
and uh
it was one of the one of the doors to
getting to know a lot of influential
muslims
even to this day but at that time it was
like a very important part of my process
and i really really thank god that you
have created this platform i really
believe that you are not aware
of the quantity of people that you have
helped because
i'm here in spain like you would never
imagine that i'm here
and my islam is being saved
thanks to many different factors and one
of them
your show alhamdulillah that's very
beautiful to hear that
tell us what were some of the proofs now
in your research
that stood out that had you confirmed
that hold on i gotta come back to this
way i gotta come back to islam
well you know the problem with this
question is that it is
uh it is too much evidence it's so much
evidence that
i believe it is an insult to islam to
try to tackle that within a few minutes
but just to you a short introduction um
[Music]
i can you know i'm like a very skeptical
person i need to check things by myself
so i've i've been reading in an internet
a lot of things about miracles of the
quran
but i actually took it upon myself to
one by one check that they were true
like for example this
mathematical miracles that you have some
words that are correlated
and they appear the same number of times
so i actually counted
one by one myself and fact checked all
of them
and i actually uh counted so many
coincidences
that it would be absurd and this is my
conclusion it would be
utterly absurd on my part to deny the
truth of islam
to such a point that it would require
complete blind faith if you know what
i'm saying
you know i really have to uh be blind in
my faith
in atheism to deny the origin the divine
origin of the quran
so i came to know a lot about this
mathematical things and the reason i
like maths is because numbers don't lie
okay
uh when you start counting all these uh
pairs of words and uh actually in some
cases words do appear in proportions
like for example if a concept is
double important of something else you
will find that it is mentioned
double i mean double the times you know
so like for example the fact that
some derivatives of the word forgiveness
appear
twice as the word justice and every time
you find the quran
talking about justice then it act then
it tells you that
forgiveness is better you know for
example so you will find
so many examples of this that
it comes a point where you cannot deny
and it's it's
no wonder that when you reject islam the
word that the quran uses
is kofo kufur doesn't mean disbelief
gopher actually means that
sorry actually can you hear did you hear
me
we hear you actually means that you are
exposed to an evidence
and you reject it or you cover it you
know so
mathematical then also from the the idea
that the quran was borrowed from the
bible
well it didn't make any sense because
when you look at the way the bible
explains the creation of the universe
and the way the quran
explains it it is as if the author of
the quran was constantly
cleaning all the all the information in
the bible which is scientifically wrong
and historically wrong
and i i'm not i'm not saying this to uh
bash the bible or anything because we
believe that the bible is partially from
god
but actually the quran's thesis
that this is a new revelation
confirming what came before but also
fixing its mistakes was much more
consistent with the facts that i was
checking one by one than the the theory
that i was sold in school that
muhammad just made up the quran by
coming from the bible
you know this is to make a very long
story short
but uh the fact of the matter is that
the evidence that the quran is from god
is like it's too overwhelming for me to
deny
but this would require a lot of hours of
of talking about it yeah people love the
the
simple message of islam and the
pure monotheism the message of just
submitting your will to the creator
not the creation and then you have in
there the moral code
the moral compass for life and i often
challenge people
find me just one thing that's in islam
that's harmful for humanity
but instead you got a whole system that
can you can run humanity not only your
house your household
or yourself as an individual but a whole
complete
blueprint for life what about the life
of the last and final messenger sent to
mankind
when you did you go deep into studying
his life and you would look
you would think you want to find
contradictions you want to see like okay
is this a fraudster
what's he up to yeah uh
that's why i was telling you that there
are too many evidences from
too many separate i mean areas
of study that it would be very hard for
me to to
just give you like a short version of it
but
this is one of the one of the main
things when you study the life of the
prophet muhammad
first of all it's very suspicious that
a human being before the modern period
his life has been recorded to such a
an extraordinary detail okay and
uh everything like fits with the
narrative of the quran the narrative of
the quran is that the prophet is the
final messenger
no more messengers coming so this has to
be preserved
and then that's what you find out the
quran is preserved
letter by letter and the biography of
the prophet himself
is preserved in such a way that even if
it was
less preserved have the quantity of
information
for some people that would be enough but
the fact that
one of the things that surprised me the
most about the biography of the prophet
is
his sincerity okay and i don't think
there is
a way that you can deny that from a
historical perspective i mean the fact
that when he went to a battle for
example
he didn't ask other people to go to
battle he was the the first one
in line you know the fact that he could
have all the riches
all the women that he whatever he wanted
he would have in life but he rejected it
and he refused that lifestyle you know
and he uh
just lived to help other people and
the fact for example that uh you
you will find is that whenever he
committed a mistake he was like very
eager
to recognize his mistake you know
like he never pretended to be
more than other people even though we
know he was much better
than than the rest of humanity you know
so this is also like the way he behaved
with his wives
the fact that he was sleeping and he
would ask permission to his wife to go
and pray
the fact that for example whenever he
had a big problem he would ask his wife
for
like advice you know the whole honesty
and how humble he was you know like
how could you how would you justify that
he was constantly
running so many risks if he knew he was
lying you know so again this is just
like uh me
trying to make it sure yeah but this is
a very deep subject
eddie you you went also deeper and you
actually got a ba in islamic studies
you didn't just stop there your
motivation and now your eagerness to
learn took you to a whole nother level
and then you also have a
an academy that you help spanish people
speaking people to learn about islam
their roots actually
yeah yeah which is funny you know it's
funny
but um i will tell you something about
the roots part but
first of all when i began to realize
that islam is the truth
i just wanted to talk about it to
everyone you know even when i was still
going out
and partying with my friends i would i
would talk about islam constantly
and every every i mean all of my friends
and my co-workers my colleagues
they respect islam so much you know
because
when they get to here i mean islam is
based on the fitra on the human
instinct so actually the human dna
has islam in it okay that's uh the one
way we could explain it
so i began to talk and talk about islam
talk about islam and i realized that
one of the proofs that this is in the
fitra is that people
usually if you explain things the right
way it resonates with them
you know so i said i need to
start i mean i need to study and and and
uh
like for example the quran i need to
start translating the quran explaining
the quran so i studied arabic
i got my ba in islamic studies now i'm
starting my studies my advanced studies
to become a scholar that's my dream
but once i finish my degree i created
the academy
and in this academy what i do is like uh
i explain the quran in spanish one of
the challenges that i had is that
many translations were like like um they
used all uh they use
words which people don't use in real
life and uh
thus sorry thus thou
the exactly in the spanish version we
also have that problem
and uh you feel like the quran is
incoherent when you read those
translations
so i really uh i really really started
to
feel the urge to explain the quran in a
way that people find it
relevant to their daily lives and at the
same time
they understand that its coherence is
actually part of this miracle
because there is no way if this book was
revealed
or composed throughout 20
throughout a 23 year span that when you
start studying its coherence
it's such an amazing uh
coherent you know so that's what i do i
i explained that in my academy i
basically
explained the quran in spanish uh
i explained it's it's rhetoric it's uh
coherence and
people people love it when you explain
things the right way people love it
where could people of the
spanish-speaking the spanish-speaking
latinos
people from who are spanish
speak the spanish language understand
how can they and they want to learn more
about islam and your academy how can
they hook up with you
well my academy is called adam academia
so if they just type www.adam
adam like the name academia a c
a d e m i a
dot com they will they will find my
courses i also have
an introduction to arabic course there i
also have a
teschia tuna like a purification of the
soul course
that is a free course for everyone and
uh i also have like a nine week program
for
spiritual uh development yeah because i
i also realized that many muslims are
like very busy
with sectarian fights and sometimes
spirituality is like
the lost it's lost people don't don't
really get into that your relationship
with your creator
that stuff so that's basically the
academy they will also find me in
instagram
i'm karami sq and i think
i think that's pretty much where they
can find me i know you're about to break
fast so we wanted to keep this short
you've been fasting all day it was a
pleasure getting some of your highlights
but inshallah we can do it again
maybe sometime after ramadan have you
back and we can go more deep
into your life your story thank you so
much for sharing that with us
it's been a pleasure for me to be here
with your brother eddie and i'm very
very grateful to god that i
finally got to meet you alhamdulillah
thank you my brother
inshallah we'll do it again sometime
thank you
salaam alaikum
all the way from spain isn't that
amazing you see what the dean does
when you come at it sincerely when you
connect with your creator
sincerely and you earnestly you want to
know the truth your earnest in your
search you're sincere and you're asking
the creator of the heavens and earth to
guide you
and then you take an analytical a
scientific approach you look at the deen
look at the evidence
look at the life of the last and final
messenger sent to mankind prophet
muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
look at the quran he said it he said it
a very good point it's insulting i mean
to islam there's
just proof upon proof so it's not one
thing there are just
countless evidences upon evidences and
it
just that a blind man can see that a
blind woman can see that a blind a human
being can see but
if the heart is dead you're not going to
see it so awaken the heart hopefully by
listening to this
this will soften up a person's heart
especially at these times where people
are just
i mean in fear living in fear you know
with this whole pandemic pandemic
whatever you want to call it going on
you know a lot of times now you're in
the rat race of life
and you're not able to think what's the
purpose of life but now you're locked up
in your homes
think you're not getting ready for the
weekend party
huh you're not going to the pubs you're
not thinking about that hopefully not
you should be thinking now about more
serious things what if it affects me
what if deaf comes to me
what has life been all about has it just
been the party in play has it just been
to chase that job
that career that business which is
lost now was it all about that or is
there something more to life
and now is your chance to think and
reflect and start with that homework ask
the creator of the heavens and earth for
guidance
do the research look into islam islam
simply means to submit your will to the
creator of the heavens and earth
and to be morally upright look into the
life of the last and final messenger
sent to mankind prophet muhammad peace
and blessings be upon him who's the
brother to jesus moses abraham noah they
all came with the same message islam
submits your will to the creator of the
heavens and earth not money not your
ideas
or none of these other things and and if
you've enjoyed this
program help us reach our
goal for this ramadan support the dean
show support our efforts we're here
to help clear the misconceptions to
deliver the purpose of life to the
people
and that all costs so support our
efforts
do your part and get the reward we'll
see you next time
until then peace be with you assalamu
[Music]
alaikum